alan wake two
we need to talk about it
during the 2021 game awards a whole
buttload of trailers were shown but one
in particular stood out to me more than
the rest and uh as you can tell
already yeah i'm talking about
alan week 2.
it's not that i'm just overly excited
for getting a sequel which obviously i
am but the thing that really started to
get me to beat my chest like a
neanderthal was what sam lake its writer
said after its review this is going to
be remedy's first ever survival horror
game
now a couple things before we get this
video started one i can't actually talk
about ellen wake without having a cup of
coffee that's basically
double
and two just a set of presidents up
front of what you should expect from
this video a lot of it's gonna be me
regaling my excitement for this
announcement but also
try to explain why alan wake's return
actually makes a whole lot of sense
right now
now we can continue going back to the
whole full-fledged survival horror thing
that allen wick
sam lake survival horror game that sam
lake mentioned and that's an incredibly
exciting prospect for ellen wake too but
in order to understand why let's let's
talk about the rocky development of alan
wake one for a second the first alan
wake went through a long and treacherous
development cycle having gone through
several iterations before becoming what
we know today as alan wake and at one
point it was supposed to be a open world
survival horror game with a day and
night cycle which tasked alan to prep
during the day to face the shadowy
figures at night until like many
development cycles go the game was
scaled back and parts were cut and it
became a fairly
more linear
action horror game rather than
a big
open world one which is interesting to
think about because alan wake one does
have quite expansive areas where you're
driving through parts of bright falls
and it's almost like you can see like
glimmers of stuff they develop for an
open world game that they just kind of
scale down into that game just just the
thought it's interesting that's all i'm
saying another thing that's kind of
interesting to think about is at the
time of which allen week came out
survival horror was well rather kind of
on the back end of existence like the
genre as a whole had taken a churn in
for a more action-oriented focus
due in part to games like resident evil
4 and resume 5. not that i'm implying
that's why alan wake became the way it
did instead of becoming
an open world survival horror game but
considering the trend and what was
mainstream at the time
i'm not surprised it took more
action-oriented route especially
considering that
remedy entertainment was coming off the
tail end of max payne
success so that's that's it but aside
from me being a survival horror nerd as
well as a big old remedy entertainment
nerd hearing sam lake say that they're
gonna go full fledged survival horror
with this upcoming sequel just
means that it feels like it's going to
be embodying what they had intended it
to be in the first place which by the
way
again is not discounting what the game
is what the first one is in its current
state it's just there's something um
magical that's the only word that's
coming ahead to my mind
magical
um
does that even make sense
am i making sense my rambling excitement
aside i do want to talk about why i
think it makes sense for alan wake to
return
now if you finish the first game you
would know that ends with a big old
cliffhanger that kind of in my opinion
ends at a satisfying conclusion but
satisfying in the horrific way like
twilight zone or the second season of
twin peaks does now going back to that
cliffhanger the game was always
developed with a sequel in mind which
sam lake just wrote in a blog post for
playstation europe announcing alan wake
too and while following it up with a
sequel immediately didn't quite come to
fruition the way remedy had intended to
instead of getting allen wake too we got
the campy sci-fi
pseudo tv show game quantum brick which
by the way i unabashedly had a great
time with even though
i can't remember
what the plot is at all but that's
besides the point overall however
quantum break just felt detached from
the identity that remedy had established
for itself from both max payne and alan
wake those games featured surreal dreamy
horrors and quirky in-game universes
that gave their seriousness and darkness
levity and those elements were pretty
much completely absent from quantum
break that game as a whole felt far more
safe which is why its follow-up control
feels like a gift from the gods of
asgard
that construction has been going on for
several weeks
and it makes me want to punch myself in
the face every single time i'm filming
here we are
that's not a gift from the gods of
asgard that is a demon
infiltrating
whatever
control wasn't just to return to
remedy's roots it was the defining
display of everything that studio
had attempted it had inventive action
technical and graphical prowess
surrealistic storytelling and top tier
world building it was also the defining
churn for the remedy connected universe
as it acknowledges alan wake and the
dark place in which he is trapped of
course if you play the control dlc awe
it's pretty obvious that a sequel was on
the way and with the recent release of
the alan wake remaster the reveal the
game awards should really come as no
surprise is it going to be open world
like their initial vision i don't know
and anything i say at this point is just
going to be armchair speculation and
backseat game design anyways
but by looking at what they did with
control and how they've innovated genres
in the past i can not wait to see what
they're gonna do with quite possibly my
favorite genre survival horror game
it's been over a decade since the first
alan wake and yet here we are and all
the pieces are in place for his grand
return but of course we'll have to wait
and see how this whole thing pans out in
2023
[Music]
god
that is so long from now
what am i gonna do
it's fine
hellblade2 is coming out that's
something to look forward to